why are we so worried about our careers
why do we care so much about our
reputations partly it's to do with money
of course but there's another more
psychological response to our fears as
well worried because we suspect not
wrongly that the world is full of a
frightening sort of person ready to
judge us ruthlessly and swiftly a person
we can call a sin op a snob is anyone
who takes a relatively small part of us
and uses it to come to a rigid and
unloggable conclusion about how much of
their attention we deserve in the past
that might have meant a snob being
interested in your lineage or royal
connections
nowadays the snob cares about one thing
only what you do for a living this
explains why the first question will be
asked in any new social context is what
do you do
I'll tell you how we answer snobs will
either welcomed us with broad smiles or
swiftly abandon us by the Peanuts the
opposite of a snob is your mother not
necessarily your mother in particular
but the ideal mother someone who doesn't
care so much what we've achieved but
instead who thinks about who we are in
the broad sense but most of the world is
not like our mothers and that's why
we're fired up by social desperate urge
to achieve and impress sometimes our
behavior is mistaken for greed and
vanity but it's more poignant than this
a lot of our interest in fancy cars jobs
and houses has nothing to do with
materialism it has to do with a hunger
for the respect and esteem that is only
available in our societies through the
acquisition of material goods it isn't
the goods themselves we seek
it's the love we stand to gain through
our possession of them the next time we
see someone driving a Ferrari
we shouldn't condemn them for their
greed we should pity them for the
intensity of their need for love from
the world at the root of snobbery is a
lack of imagination and confidence about
how to decide who in the world is
valuable
the snob isn't wrong in
background sense that there are better
or worse sorts of people around they are
just brutally misguided and slavish in
evidence about how the superior
individuals can be identified for snobs
it's the already acclaimed and the
already successful who are the only ones
worthy of respect
there isn't rule in their till
regimented Minds to imagine that someone
might be clever kind or good and yet
somehow have been overlooked entirely by
society their quality is lurking beneath
an unfamiliar guys
however yet discovered no obvious
outlets touchingly the personal origins
of snobbery typically lying horns who
were themselves snores and therefore
never endowed their offspring or the
confidence to judge each new person on
their own terms without reference to
social status income and reputation
despite their commitment to surrounding
themselves by people of high status
ironically snobs constantly failed to
spot who might one day be fated out
border they are misled by the unexpected
outward forms that brilliance often
takes snobs don't sign up the Beatles
don't invest in the startup iteration of
Google or Apple don't give the time of
day to the taxi driver who might one day
be the president or the old lady in a
woolly hat writing the great novel of
the 21st century the true answer to
snobbery is not to say that there's no
such thing as a writer or worst person
but to insist that better
IRA's exists in constantly unexpected
places and carry none of the outward
signs of distinction and because we are
such poor judges of the worth of others
our ultimate duty remains to be kind
good curious and imaginative about
pretty much everyone who ever crosses
our path
and that includes ourselves
you